e cacchiate d'oro
oggi scappiamo
prossimo non è nuovissima per il rombo
lasciato mar mi piace mettere le comodi
prendi qualcosa da mangiare qualcosa
fisico mi piace il mio nuovo outfit con
le stelline buche camera da letto il
leader che t'ho bianco ecco un marinaio
vediamo che cosa dice cosa dice che io
ho sentito che sta succedendo qualcosa
di strano nella nave vuoi andare a
controllare lo show non abbiamo
controllato controlliamo subito ci
stanno chiudendo dentro era una trappola
ci siamo affrontati subito ricerca
vivano i penso sia lui che è impazzito e
intrappolata nella mia nave ad esse
capitano impazzito dobbiamo scappare eh
sì dobbiamo scappare a come ok
sbrighiamoci scappiamo proviamo a
prendere una di quelle barchette piccoli
[Musica]
alle freccette miccoli stagionale 9 si
sbraccia era vitale scrivete nei
commenti vediamo chi riesce ad arrivare
al numero esatto chi si avvicinerà di
più il numero esatto c'è una marchetta
si può poco sul fondo va bè metti io non
ti posso aspettare non posso tornare
indietro sto facendo tutto da sola
questa barca non so dove mi sta portando
ci sono vari e isolette ero dietro
sto aspettando la prossima barca dai
sbrigati se non rimane che stavo per
cadere mou mi sta portando miglia
però c'è un polpo gigante in quest'isola
anita cade attacco tu hai presto la
barca si sono poi dietro ciao ciao
previsto soltanto ciò che faremo paravia
ok riproviamo questa volta devo stare
attenta mio sacco di tolbà perché mi
porta proprio in quella dove c'è quel
polpo gen un così sarai lazio non può
superare i ott il primo finire l'escape
rombo vediamo
ce l'ho fatta aspetta un attimo
no mi sono gelato
ma come l'impressione che adesso il
polipo ci mangeranno sì penso proprio di
sì così possiamo vedere che cosa ha
mangiato il polipo beh sicuramente
sempre cose in terra africana wire mai
lo sapete la lingua è questa no è un
tentacolo forse i
ii iii strasse lamento di vitale per me
ancora il primo piano piano piano il
polipo ha mangiato delle paperelle di
gomma
sfracella vento di vitale e anche dei
capelli di marina
[Musica]
francese lamento
perché il polipo vangi marinai forse
questa è la cosa strana che stava
succedendo qualche dissidio di colmare
in ohio cattivo cioè capitale ma dove è
finito evitare quando c'è il suo pezzo
preferito nella cacca che accetto d'oro
io sono già passato ha fatto che sono
troppo bravo ma non è possibile tutti
stranieri sempre ora dimmi come ita sono
diventato troppo tra rocca sono
diventato troppo bravo ed evitare le
cassette vahidi siete team celeste o
team stelline celeste no ciao ciao ciao
presto raggiungiamo lo do do
che il procedimento è qui
ottavo no non credo che iniziata non ci
credo la mia score non riesco proprio
passare da qui mi viene che sfrecciano
sempre e anita già passata avanti
no
no quindi bisogna saltare sopra i tubi
in
una di queste porte si porterà a
sottomarino
motori anche qua dobbiamo scegliere la
porta giusta vi ricordate le altre
sprung in cui dovevamo se nella porta
giusta talora l'attività andate a vedere
questa
no devo tornare i dubbi
accettiamo sfracellando in continuazione
che il piano piano se si tratta di
istologia il depuratore adesso ho preso
lo portò giusta a il collega laporta lo
dico finalmente ce l'ho fatta quindi hai
detto questa
vita va avanti
allora andiamo ad aprire il ponte per
accedere al sottomarino che è stato
marino giallo come io voglio andare nel
sottomarino
piazza
devo raggiungere vitale
beh io però ti sto superando in
sfracella mente e infatti dovevano
contare i tuoi strage lamentino dice
troppo il bottone per aprire le monte
per arrivare dall'altra parte ecco il
bottone papà papà
[Musica]
guarda vita sono fati troppo breve
guarda
avanti sbrigarmi ma teso ma com'è
possibile che michele diventa ciò che
sei bravo lo è la stampa rosa parte solo
fortuna non sono però solo sul lato
che carisa e queste paperelle addominali
non c'entra no no 1 non si può riposare
un attimo allora dobbiamo superarlo
speriamo vita niente parole
non mi avrai dei frati forse sono
riuscito a salvare sismici salvare la
supervelocità
preparati per portare a
tutti e due vediamo che dice o no
bisogna stare attenti agli uccelli
mortali e infatti sono qui ma sono solo
gabbiani
stiamo prepar tappa no pure a me la
felicità
di
fatto non è giusto che bello tutto
stiamo è un faro e siglato sia al faro
vt la vediamo nella ix presto tenere
l'equilibrio un piano piano piano i
gabbiani mi stanno massacrando le sei
[Musica]
figo stiamo andando con il cavo sulla
nave ei allontanati ste robe che cade
non sono solo frutto con occupy proprio
adesso salta
così guarda 9 il vapore della nave si
pensa che devi evitarlo non c'è problema
siamo proprio
[Risate]
io ho preso il valore della nave il mio
press trova la chiave
bene qua possiamo guadagnare tempo nel
frattempo che è vitale si sfracella
musei sono già qui
ma sti qua dietro
copione della metro per la chiave è
salvato chi è
quello il badge
fermo fermo no
no prezzo apriva vitale ed indovina chi
è il vincitore team celeste ma siccome
avete schepp roma è stata veloce
proviamo subito un'altra ep
provincia ora proviamo diamante da ieri
via
siamo c'è scritto
vicino quindi dobbiamo rubare un
diamante e mi ha
salvato adesso però dobbiamo andare
[Musica]
chi viaggerà in quanto a te promedio
vitale chissà chissà
questa musica mette un po l'ansia che
quindi non ci dobbiamo far scoprire come
ha fatto strage allarme non l'avevo
vista ecco vitale che devono andar via
marte anzi lo devo prendere prima io
voglio la rivincita detto che prima hai
vinto tu essa chissà chi vincerà
a chi in fasce sono i pali elettrici e
dove stiamo dentro nella banca dobbiamo
trovare qui c'è qualcuno c'è un amico
ladro ma
siamo usciti per strada un museo
dobbiamo rubare il diamante amico
wow un'idea fuori di kirwan l'ipad che
dobbiamo trovare una chiave primaria
ripresa e gigante questa chiara spero
che il diamante ata vitale tortellata
spero che il diamante sarà gigante devo
prenderla prima io
ho già superato
o vi vuole this verso 6 che senza da
visivo è solo uno di questi passata
quando siamo nati siamo dentro un museo
finalmente in ciliegio
di seeding esposizione egizia ma senza
musica ma cos'è questo ruggeri sta
sparando
a stanno cadendo nei sassi ma perché
caso ritratto in un museo
non è molto sicuro
infine a chi è avanti io sono al livello
18 di tournée mi ha superato la piramide
che bello c'è una pirofila fa dietro
dove quella che sta entrando adesso
entrato in una piramide si no sarà la
dentro il diamante
potrebbero sai
come ho fatto l'intera piramide ad
entrare dentro il museo è in effetti un
po strano
eccovi dove credi di scappare oslo
quanto sembra uscito a taglio andiamo lì
sono finiti
nella io ho sentito a volte chiudo
spesso wow
siamo nella sezione dello spazio gabella
e gireremo tutto il museo per trovare
questo diamante indovina chi è
velocissimo qui non può vincere di nuovo
vitaliano bizzare io come facciamo
adesso a salire penso che dobbiamo
aspettare eccolo
[Musica]
allora aspettiamo aspettiamo aspettiamo
ok bisogna stare nei video si sia
preso si sono riuscito a passare
non ci credo vitale mi ha superato
si è anche di tanto
dai ti aspetto per lanciare il missile
ce l'ho fatta finalmente state più buffa
dobbiamo far partire il missile che li
vedi qui c'è il bottone
facciamo partire il ds
premi
e ora che succede ecco per tutto e
adesso dobbiamo andare forse dobbiamo
andare qui sì ma anche come stiamo
facendo però scappando con la nave di
pirati dei caraibi siamo nella sezione
pirati come prima nelle nove dei primi a
bacchetta i pesci
[Musica]
sono stata solo un pesce pagliaccio
il primo mi piace ancora nella prima
perché ha un sacco di stage di verde oro
super diva come quale piace di più la
prima e la seconda cioè quest'acqua
vitale si straccerà manteneva sgreccia
sono qui dietro di te ero lì dietro
l'inter
evviva finalmente sono avanti e ho
superato vitale questo ho continuato a
sfracellare qui bene meglio così stiamo
per uscire dalla sezione pirati da
crociera ecco vitale
vediamo cos'altro si aspetta adesso in
questo museo gigante quale sarà la
prossima avventura chi siamo
il castello è
attento la squadra io
perché ce l'ho fatta
che bel castello
il giallo e il giallo lo considera muto
mi avevi paura che la bugia vitale e
avanti adesso c'è un dinosauro gigante
qui o che carino non sembrano di rinaudo
sembra una rana appena mangiato ha di
nuovo la tua parte preferita sembra uno
stagno qui
te l'ho detto che era una sorta di rara
ma si
sa non vorrei dire ma io sono in
vantaggio
lo senti il cuore sì
noi dobbiamo prendere la porta giusta
non è quella rossa io provo con questa
proviamo questa quindi non è la bianca
sono tutte le blu e ti sto aiutando i
blu mi sa che blu
mi sa che siamo in quel posto lì e di
già per capitale smantellato dai questo
era facile a meno che per conto di
quante volte si è sfracellato ma tu sei
già troppo avanti diamante laggiù
davvero che strana avventura ma guarda
siamo arrivati al diamante
il problema è che ci sono i poliziotti
che lo stanno
controllando
come prenderlo
ma io devo vincere dopo vincere ei non
vi farò prendere diamante
non so perché non me l'ha fatto forte ho
capito perché tornerà dopo
troviamo chiave della chiave
sarà sì l'ho trovata dove qui
abbiamo
c'è qualcosa di strano qua perché che
cosa c'è non lo so però dice ci
dovrebbero un bottone da vicino per
aprire il portone e colorato bravo e
quel bottone wow
ma anche tanto dobbiamo trovare una
porta per uscire da questo garage ma non
l'avevamo appena aperta la porta menta
fatti era questa no se qualcosa ma
eccolo guarda chi viene qui per questo
caso autobot dire vitale e brahms game
room
attento e veloce questi container
ma quindi l'abbiamo preso il diamante
non ho capito
nostra giornata di nuovo eccomi ti
amiamo dove dobbiamo andare in questo
tunnel si manca poco ormai ci siamo
quasi cosa dice stiamo per arrivare a
casa manca ancora poco e mal diamante
l'ha presa lui
manca poco ultimo
è visto giusto alla fine
non vi è piaciuta di più la prima la
seconda me questa costa era super carina
infatti da super colorato mi piace
lasciate un bel mi piace della vita su
altre cose diversi pubblicare per vedere
i nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
ciao